let's get into some dangerous territory
here one of the questions i get asked
all the time is am i getting the coven
19 vaccine
right so here's the deal i'm going to
tell you what i'm going to do
but i want to talk about the process
first because i think the process
is important for making this decision
any kind of decision right
one of my life philosophies is to always
have
an expert like do you know a guy do you
know a gal
do you know a person who knows something
about this thing
right and this is the deal
i'm not that smart i went to a lot of
school and i studied a couple of things
really deeply
but i'm not that smart the thing i'm
most smart about
is what i don't know right which is a
lot
plumbing no idea i got a guy cable
barrett
right i mean bear cable barrett cable
his name is barrett cable not cable
barrett
building how to build something i'm
embarrassing i'm humil
i am i am shameful at how i can try to
build stuff
but lucky i got a guy charlie turner
winston cruz
i know guys who know guys right legal
scholarship right how do i
interpret a new legal ruling i could go
to the internets
and it's going to give me a bunch of
nonsense headlines and drama
nope i got rob cassie tracy alex darby
dustin
i got folks that i call because i'm not
a legal scholar
i don't know banking todd uh funny memes
plus and caleb investments chris hogan
my buddy craig swann right
education my wife the other the doctor
sheila deloney
dr mark phillips dr stephanie talley
trucks anything trucks i call my buddy
michael
internet things kevin right counseling
dr
janet dr lin dr steve dr brett dr aretha
et cetera et cetera here's the thing
we are the worst at being honest about
what we don't know
we have tons of opinions but very little
knowledge
we read a headline we watch a youtube
clip and we consider ourselves
experts right worse we form an opinion
something that we really want to be true
or we hear something and we think that's
not
right and we go searching for anyone
on the internets anyone to back us up
right and here's the thing you can go
down a rabbit hole
and you will find some dude in the back
of his car in the trunk
recording a youtube show with 11
followers
and they will he will come up with the
thing that you think
right so back to the cova vaccine when
it comes to the science of vaccines
i don't know and i know a lot about
science i know a lot about research
about biology i don't know about
vaccines i'm not an epidemiologist i'm
not a research biologist or a virologist
and you aren't either right
and i misjudged this thing out of the
gate big time
so i called my friend who's the dean of
a pharmacy school
a good pharmacy school he's a close
buddy he's brilliant he's a research
scholar
and so i called him and i said hey what
do you think man are you getting this
this vaccine and he said man i read the
science
um it's better than i could have ever
dreamt
and so me and my family yeah we're for
sure getting it i'll be first in line be
i'll get as soon as they're allowed me
and my first thought was ah
sucker dean of a pharmacy school you're
in bed with big pharma i knew it
i knew it right so i called the chair of
a biology by the way
he's a good friend and i think i said
that exact thing to his face so
um i called the chair of a biology
department a cancer researcher at
another university
right i changed college universities
changed genders
stupid guys i'm going to call a
brilliant woman cancer researcher
said hey you getting this vaccine and
she told me the science was so
impressive
so much more impressive than she could
have thought the vaccines really aren't
that complicated
she was part of the trial and things
have been great
i said you that's ridiculous so i called
my minister
and that sucker was part of a trial too
and i just thought i'm being
failed by everybody everyone i needed
you to back up my opinion
i knew somebody close friend i've known
her for almost 30 years oh my gosh i'm
getting old i've done it forever
i called her she's a homeopathic doctor
i've got you vaccinators now
uh hey this is even better a homeopathic
doctor on the west coast
booyah called her we talked for a long
time about the science
she's a brilliant researcher
practitioner and she said this is
causing a ton of challenges
but i'll get it as soon as i'm able i'm
gonna sign up and get it
so i asked three different experts
plus a minister hey what's the deal on
this deal
and they said not only are we doing it
but we would give it to our families
i'll be first in line my medical friends
they did it so here's the thing
when it comes to medical advice
psychological advice etc please go into
these things with an open mind
don't try to find somebody to back up
your opinion
because there are a billion people
trying to just put their nonsense their
opinion their attitude
some scandalous conspiracy theory out
there right
so am i getting the vaccine yeah for
sure because i don't know enough about
it
but i do know four people who i trust
deeply
have said yeah this is something we're
doing for ourselves
if it was available for our kids and the
research meets our kids which it hasn't
yet
we would do that too but there's not
been research on kids so we're not there
yet
i trust them when it comes to getting on
internets right i
trust dr tia dr rhonda patrick robert
zaplowski
gabor mate right ben greenfield because
of their longevity
they're researched back understanding
their personal experiences
right i got two phds i've years of
working with folks and i'm not afraid to
say this magic thing
i was wrong and all those people i just
mentioned they've said the phrase
man i was wrong too i had to rethink
this thing
things change i learn more i'm growing
right
so i trust folks but i put a lot of
energy into trusting
figuring out why i should trust them and
it's because of their expertise
sometimes because of their education
sometimes because of their experience
sometimes because they've been in this
thing for a long time sometimes because
they'll say the words i was wrong
i misjudged this i got new information
so i changed what i understood
and they are humble and more importantly
they do these things with themselves
they do these things with their kids
and when i i can ask somebody all day
long hey
um what do you think and they're going
to give me a dissertation
but then i ask them hey what are you
doing with your kids and they'll say
yeah what are you doing with yourself do
you actually take this supplement
do you actually plan on getting a line
to get that vaccine and they'll say yeah
i did
so i'm going to because the folks who
know more have said it's a great idea
and if i'm wrong and this is a massive
money grab and we all die
here's the thing i don't want to live in
a world where all the doctors and
surgeons and nurses and leaders and
teachers and social workers and mental
health professionals where they've all
died anyway so
there we go i'm ready to go too so
that's my thought on the covenant team
vaccine but more importantly than that
that's how i go about solving some of
these problems i
don't default to my opinion my bad
attitude
some conspiracy theory or some angry
person on the internet
i try to get deeper than that and go to
experts who know
what they're talking about right